une vague de grève inédite à présent aux
états unis tous secteurs confondus du
jamais vu depuis
1968 des milliers de travailleurs sont
en grève pour réclamer de meilleures
conditions de travail des salariés
épuisé par la pandémie voyez les
explications de notre correspondant à
washington thomas bonnin
le mouvement a été renommé strike touba
or contraction de strike qui veut dire
grève en anglais et 2 octobre heure des
milliers de travailleurs américains sur
l'ensemble du pays ont sorti le piquet
de grève au mouvement salué par l'ale
gauche du parti démocrate
alexandria occasio cortese en tête
épuisée par près de deux ans de pandémie
les salariés ont donc décidé de s'unir
pour obtenir de meilleures conditions de
travail
illustration avec ses salariés de
kellogg célèbre vendeur de céréales
devant leur usine du nebraska
ils veulent que tous les riches restent
riches et que nous restions à terre
il y a dix huit mois nous étions
considérés comme des employés est
essentielle notre pdg nous traiter de
héros maintenant quand il est temps de
nous donner et à tous les membres du
syndicat un accord équitable cela ne se
produit pas
l'entreprise affirme que c'est la
première fois depuis 1972 que ces
salariés céréaliers sont en grève et
d'autres secteurs sont concernés le
domaine de la santé les fabricants de
tracteurs ou encore l'industrie
cinématographique la semaine dernière à
hollywood un accord a été trouvé évitant
de justesse une grève des équipes de
tournage alors ce mouvement s'explique
par la conjoncture économique américaine
les états unis manque de main d'oeuvre
et les salariés ont bien compris qu'ils
étaient donc en position de force il est
difficile aujourd'hui d'estimer avec
précision le nombre de grévistes sur
l'ensemble du pays mais certains
avancent le chiffre de cent mille
personnes qui seraient donc actuellement
en grève aux etats unis une chose est
sûre ce mouvement social est un fait
plutôt rare au pays du libéralisme la
pandémie ayant fait ressurgir des
frustrations chez certains salariés face
aux profits records de quelques
entreprises on assiste donc à un
phénomène de contagion et à un nombre
croissant de grévistes